- [Narrator] Jo Jorgensen
is the Libertarian Party's
nominee for president in 2020,
and the only candidate on
the ballot in all 50 States,
other than Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
A recent NPR poll showed
her pulling 5% nationally,
which could cover the spread between
the President and his challenger.
According to a chorus of
pundits and partisans though,
voting for a third party
candidate is a waste,
because it doesn't change
the high-stakes battle
to either toss out or keep in
office Donald Trump in 2021.
- This is not the time to
withhold our votes and protests
or play games with candidates
who have no chance of winning.
- [Narrator] Jorgensen,
a 63-year-old Clemson
psychology lecturer, is
running on a blend of standard,
small government rhetoric
disgust with career politicians,
optimism about young people,
and of course the occasional craziness
that we all expect from
third party nominees.
- I am running for
president because government
is too big, too bossy,
too nosy, too intrusive.
But the worst part is,
they usually end up hurting
the very people they're trying to help.
- [Narrator] She says
that most of her followers
are either Independents
or first time voters.
And that the real mistake would be
to vote for Trump or Biden.
Particularly in parts of the
country where a principled vote
is unlikely to impact the final outcome.
- I would say if you're in a
solidly red state, like I'm in,
if you don't like what
Donald Trump has been doing,
if you don't like the bigger
government he's given you,
then voting for him is a wasted vote.
And to Democrats, especially
Democrats in California,
in New York, don't vote for Joe Biden,
vote for what you really want.
- [Narrator] Jorgensen who ran
as the LPs vice presidential
nominee back in 1996, wants
to bring all the troops home,
cut the size of government
in half, legalize drugs,
and in our interview, suggested replacing
Ruth Bader Ginsburg on the Supreme court
with someone like
82-year-old Alan Dershowitz.
Though she later recanted
on social media because
of his statements that torture
may sometimes be acceptable,
his opposition to gun rights,
and what she called unresolved questions
about his association
with Jeffrey Epstein.
Jorgensen says that
Republicans have failed
to live up to their promises
of fiscal discipline.
- A lot of people don't realize
that government grew year
after year after year for eight
straight years with Reagan.
People keep saying,
"Oh, look at Donald
Trump, we got tax cuts."
Well yeah, but he increased spending,
so the bill is eventually
going to come due.
He came in saying, "I'm a businessman,
"I know how to balance a budget,
"I know how to cut spending",
and he didn't do that.
And not only did he not cut
spending, he increased spending.
Now we've got a bigger
deficit, bigger debt.
Whether you're talking education,
healthcare, retirement,
it all boils down to,
are you in control of your dollars?
- [Narrator] Biden, says Jorgensen,
has shamelessly pandered to
voters for nearly 50 years.
- People wanted to hear
him say I'm tough on crime,
so he said, I'm tough on crime.
And now they want to hear something else,
so he's something else,
he doesn't have a rudder.
He doesn't have something
that's guiding him.
That's true not only about Biden,
but pretty much any Democrat out there.
Young people are shocked to
hear that both Hillary Clinton
and Barack Obama were
against gay marriage,
just back in 2012, that
was only eight years ago.
- [Narrator] Speaking of young people,
Jorgensen is big on Gen Z.
Arguing that young Americans
are less about cancel culture
and being woke and more
about being Laissez-faire.
- They go, well, why shouldn't
you be able to own a gun?
Why shouldn't two people
the same sex get married?
If you can drink red wine,
why can't you smoke marijuana?
So, that overall they have
a very libertarian underpinning
as far as their kind of live and let live
libertarian philosophy,
so that's excellent news.
If I could sit around the kitchen table
of every American family in this country,
I would win by a landslide.